it's like you wear the baby as a
backpack but it's on your front whatever
that's called a papoose
is that what it's called a purpose
very nice and then they all say
ergonomic on them nowadays because
that's a word that we now like
unergonomic purposes kill people i don't
know ergonomic means it like works with
your body well yeah it should have
always been ergonomic one of these words
that you've used to like skin friendly
soap yeah i was hoping that it was going
to be skin friendly i was going to use
it on my skin
alfie brown welcome to the show thanks
so much for having me it's a real
pleasure to be here it's a pleasure to
have you last night was halloween how
did you
how did you spend your halloween
um i
always uh spend my halloween with the
lights off uh with my knees tucked uh in
between my arms pretending that i'm not
in
uh so that i don't have to i'm like and
that is that's the way i've been for
about the last decade so to now have
kids that want to to have to be more
involved
the the tiny involvement that i used to
have as a as a man with no children
has now been just
so greatly
uh
exaggerated and has
has galloped forth into this most
unpleasant of areas um so
i just don't have the same
patience faculty for other people's
children as i do for mine
quite understandably from an
evolutionary perspective i why would i
care about them but that means like to
tolerate them is such a
it is
such a drain on your resources as a
human being
so uh my i was lucky i looked after my
baby whilst my uh girlfriend took my
uh two elder children out
trick-or-treating but
the day before my was my son's birthday
party he had a uh seventh birthday party
and uh and it was a halloween themed
thing so we all
played games and
i got them all to do their scariest
laughs and i had to kind of like compare
the thing there's no scarier gig than
that comparing a child's birthday party
man oh man it was a nightmare
uh
that was the true halloween experience
i love how you're you've been sort of
labeled as he's a performer you're used
to being on stage aren't you i mean
comedian childs before i'd go six and
two three you must have all you've got
the mics i mean you've got the skills
you can do this
people just presume that you're used to
being on stage so you can do kids stuff
i said this the other day on uh
but i'll i'm happy to
say it again um
i have performed at cardiff
uh junglers
which is in an oceana with fish tanks
that sort of um blockade the hen parties
in
so that they can't leave i think i was
on about 11 o'clock at night because the
gig had been delayed so all they'd had
to do was drink and that audience still
had more of a kind of semblance of care
about my ego
than the seven-year-olds and as soon as
you display any sort of like i'm a cool
fun guy who likes kids the children will
just start hitting you
where can you tell me about that can
anybody can a psychologist please report
to me on
how or why children as soon as they
are just hit you now
three of them because they like because
i did silly scary funny laughs
i'll get him now
that was them showing
affection yeah is it like pulling on my
pigtails is that what it's like like
saying i like you so i'll hit you
because i don't know how to express
myself because my brain's not fully
developed
is that what it is
i've absolutely no idea but um i think i
did quite a good
job the weird thing is because of the
kind of comedy that i do lots of people
have always um
uh
like crappy compares have always taken
me off stage by going um there's alfie
brown he is available for children's
parties
well yeah i i
am and i'm pretty good
pretty good at it actually managed not
to say anything awful did a kind of
light-hearted joke the parents liked it
you know it was a it was actually a
really lovely day and the crucial thing
was it only lasted three hours very very
very nice i think my uh my business
partner has
he's got three little ones he's got a
three four month old
two-year-old and a four-year-old
and two dogs
and a wife and i'm pretty sure that they
managed to coordinate an outfit
they were all werewolves including the
dogs
yesterday so they went out
trick-or-treating
my business partners got one of those
it's like you wear the baby as a
backpack but it's on your front whatever
that's called a papoose
is that what it's called a purpose
very nice it's it's it's it's called a
and then they all say ergonomic on them
nowadays because that's the word that we
now like because
unergonomic purposes
kill people or whatever it is well yeah
just garage sales
break your kids ribs i don't know
ergonomic means it like works with your
body well yeah it should have always
been ergonomic it's one of these words
that you've used to like skin friendly
soap yeah i was hoping that it was going
to be skin friendly i was going to use
it on my skin
anyway um
yes that sounds good i didn't quite i
wanted to be the joker
uh oh you've kind of got the hair if you
could if you could dye it you could kind
of pull a little bit of the the
hairstyle off yeah i think so i think i
mean depending on which era joker i
think i the one i'd most like to be is
jack nicholson and nowadays i think he's
the most kid friendly i don't think you
can go as in-cell joker to a
seven-year-old's birthday party
can you
black pill black the theme of this kid's
party is the black pill
[Laughter]
okay so you didn't do the joker
uh no no no there just wasn't the time
between you know
working and trying to sell
uh
myself
um essentially in the various different
mediums that it's incumbent upon one to
sell oneself uh
there just wasn't time to go into the
soho and pick up a big purple suit or
whatever it was i would have liked to
have done and i didn't want to half-ass
it so what did you rely what did you go
as then
i was i went dad's to a chill a dad to a
children's birthday party that sounds a
lot like non-metal
uh i well i i didn't actually go with
anything i just went as myself okay i
didn't i didn't dress up yeah none of
the adults dressed up ah so how did you
have gone as a joker you would have been
the only one
yeah
but i was as the kind of host of the
event i thought that would have been
appropriate you know because it gives
you the illusion of authority
uh yeah and i'm the one you know what
i'm for if i'm the one that's dressed up
don't you you know that i'm the one
that's about to
be like you can't it almost looks weird
that i'm joining in all the children's
games not dressed up i just look like a
kind of creepy over-enthusiastic adult
whereas if i was in like a kit then
everybody got okay good that's what his
role tonight is yeah he's the authority
here he's aesthetically provided us with
context for the way he's behaving i was
just seeing me in a cotton oxford shirt
who this who's this creep
getting hit by my kid
loser stop talking to reuben
my business partners my business
partner's kid's called reuben so he's
i'm pretty adamant that
darren has
crawled out of the working class on the
shoulders of his children's names
[Laughter]
yes
ruben
cooper
and zara with a h
wow
wow beautiful names beautiful kids
[ __ ]
dream family but i do have to remind him
every so often that he's from adol in
leeds
and
no matter
how fancy the names are that you give
your children
you're always going to be from that
maybe he's a business owner as well oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah so like he's he he
is he's cr he has a
reboot i i i don't think i should say
the word crawled but um you can say
crawled i suppose uh i i it doesn't
sound well when a posh bloke says it
um
uh
yeah yeah i might that's what i'm always
reminding my friend um
uh vaz about is that kind of class
changes he's much more middle class than
i am just because i because he came from
hounslow and i came from
you know a leafy suburb of west london
uh and now
he
you know likes um
cooking with sandfire and drinking red
wine and
a star of a niece and i don't know he's
he's a he's actually a brilliant
brilliant cook
uh and um
uh but class is what's the what's the
word it's you can you can move it shifts
about yeah
that's what my mom did she was
she was uh
you know a working class girl and then
became middle class
and then she had a middle class child
and now i'm
earning a very working class
i did all of this work
do you know how hard it worked to
[ __ ] get us out of this class mobile
that's what i was trying to think of
chosen chosen the only career that could
have sent you back a generation yeah
yeah yeah
entertainment [ __ ]
[ __ ] as a as a as a as a completely
unmarketable
uh human man why do you think why
unmarketable what's wrong with what's
what's the challenge with the marketing
um i don't think i have a strong enough
identity i think people uh
you need to be good at
have you ever written a treatment for a
tv program i know what they are uh when
you write a treatment for a tv program
uh you have something underneath the
title called a log line which is
essentially you know the program is uh
it's
called the show is called red and uh
it's a sitcom uh it's like
uh only fools and horses meets a
caravanning holiday and that's what it
is it's only for all the horses meek to
calera and that's oh okay i know exactly
what it is i almost don't need to read
the rest of this because everything i'm
about to read has been so informed by
the log line
and i think as a comedian now
you need to have a good log line
and i don't have a good log line
i mean at least i don't
it's fairly nondescript i suppose having
children helps and uh
the style of comedy that i do sort of
helps most of my shows have
uh thematically
um similar
structures and not structures but
they're thematically similar i should
say
um
and
i maybe it's one of those things like uh
you and i were speaking about
when it's you you're a very bad judge of
what it is
uh
but i even think the way that i i was
thinking about this and i don't think it
like looks particularly good or maybe
likeable or maybe it's again me
overthinking it that
when we think about how we dress i think
about how we're aesthetically presenting
ourselves especially as somebody who's
on stage performing and delivering
a set of ideas to an audience and
performing them with some sort of
attitude that befits well i've made
decisions about i've made a decision to
have a beard albeit that might be
because
i just thought it might be a good way to
put my chin into the singular
[Laughter]
i've made a decision about everything so
why not i i wear these shirts these kind
of nondescript cotton oxford shirts from
business suit kind of providers and
think why am i
hiding uh so much so maybe
thinking more in these terms about how
we're
um
uh presenting ourselves isn't
something to be sniffed at i think
comedy purists have this idea whereby
they think
well i just want to do jokes and i'm a
joke purist but i think the whole
element of performance just because
uh cinema is a visual medium doesn't
mean that we don't think
uh about the music or about the
font of the titles or uh and it's all
cohesive whatever it's all cohesive yeah
and i think i need to be thinking a
little bit more
in uh cohesively about things like my
log line and my aesthetic
if you look at the pictures for the last
series of live at the apollo
they're all dressed like cartoon
characters like every and it's great
they all look great everybody on it
looks everybody looks great uh but
uh
they all are dressed
as an in statement pieces yeah it's like
archetypes right it's the same as when
you have a tv show and you know that the
maiden is got big eyes and the villain
wears black and the heroes sort of
muscled like this and the nerd's got
glasses and it's a shortcut because it
it's an energy saving device for our
brains i don't need to work out oh hang
on a second i i had this vision of him
but then he's added this bit on the side
like a lump of clay that doesn't look
like it's supposed to be there and
what's that bit because that bit i
thought i thought i had this sphere this
perfect round ball that was a box that i
could put him in
but now there's this bit on the side of
it and um
yeah that's i i think about this a lot
actually uh i did a tedx talk at the
start of the year about something very
similar about the fact that
we live our lives and archetypes and we
we look to the examples that other
people set
and that
that cohesion that ease of uh being able
to work out
what someone is what someone's what
someone's got going on
it lends uh it makes affinity more easy
with people um but the problem is if you
don't fall into one of those archetypes
naturally you end up having to be
performative in order to do that so a
lot of people
they are friends with others based on a
performance a role that they're playing
of the person that they think their
friends want them to be so i see this
with young guys a lot i
do a lot of nightlife and you see this i
was one of them i was a professional
party boy for a decade as a guy who now
wants to talk about whether you can
genetically engineer human life to reach
the star systems or the philosophical
basis for good like that
so standing on the front door of a
nightclub was never facilitating that
but i'd created this this person
that i could be because it was effective
and and and people could could get it
all right chris yeah yeah but yeah big
name on campus yeah yeah yeah shagging
in that and that was
the persona um
but the sacrifice that you make is that
if you don't fall into one of those
character characteristics at one of
those archetypes that you end up having
to kind of shave bits off you
uh how conscious is this persona like at
the time if you're saying this persona
that you had he's you know party boy
great night out good pint good shagger
whatever uh
big shagger not good i couldn't possibly
comment um
but
how when you're in because that's 10
years are you going home the next day
going god i really
better read more about
aristotle's eudaimonia no no no so that
that was um me just doing the thing that
i thought would get me popular so all i
was trying to do was please other people
and
my route to doing that was
split testing a type of me and then when
one of them was successful just
continuing to go down it but it wasn't
it wasn't thought out in advance it
wasn't done reflectively and it took
10 years and then a season of love
island for me to go oh [ __ ] what how did
i get here this really doesn't feel
there's something wrong and then you do
a ton of self work and inquiry and you
scrape off all of the mud and the the
feces that has accumulated on top of the
person you are and then eventually you
get to something that approximates truth
right you end up going right all of this
that i thought i was all of these
opinions i had all of these ideas about
the world all of these ways of living
all of the things that i held up in
esteem and all the things that i didn't
okay right what have i what have i got
left well [ __ ] knows i'll just keep
going keep digging keep digging keep
digging and then eventually you hit
something that seems a bit more firm and
you're okay maybe i can maybe i can
start speaking some truth forward from
here
wow that's so interesting that's so
interesting the difference and also kind
of but it's also terrifying in a way
because if you're
uh
enveloped in
something that is um i'm not sure if
artifice is the right word but a
construction based on
something
uh
exteri
based on trying to find yourself based
on a
things
that are exterior rather than
interior like outwardly reflecting and
letting the outward
realm affect
who you are and who you present yourself
as it's just um
if you can
i mean do you feel like that's like lost
time or important time i imagine you're
kind of quite stoic about the whole
thing yeah it's just it's it was time
you know maybe that was the route
maybe
it was time uh
i i i couldn't i was like something yoda
would say
there is no good or bad there is just
time
um
yeah there was no alternative you know i
i discovered the thing when i discovered
the thing i realized that there was a
discordance between the person i was and
the persona i was playing when i
discovered it and
that
that came about now the difference and
the difficulty that i can see with
yourself
is that
comedic personas
they they're important and i've actually
taken over the last couple of months uh
my comedy coach dec
has been working with me and i i just
wanted to become
learn how comedy works i thought this
would be fun it's a good skill to
acquire
the first thing that he started talking
about was comedic personas about the
fact that you have an offering that kind
of positions you in terms of power it's
that i know
what this person is when they step on
stage right you know peter k you know he
comes out on stage very strong comedic
persona you understand you you get him
um someone with a much more sort of
subtle comedic persona would be like a
james a caster perhaps because it's kind
of like a bit like okay is it is he is
he is he sort of being childish is he
being kind of like funny is he awkward
is he cool and then he's pivoted with
this most recent one and he's like
pretending to be a rock star type thing
um but i think that works in the context
of his former shows though like we we
now that we know who james a caster is
it's really interesting to see james
cake has to
break who we thought he was yeah that
was really really really exciting i mean
i think that he was very good at
i think it's
it is more subtle than peter kay's
persona
you know i i i suppose but i don't think
that uh
i think that james a caster was
brilliant at building this
uh aesthetic brilliant at building you
know in advance had three shows that
began with r and had a similar style
poster and did them all in a row in
edinburgh and they were all kind of
brilliant similar but different enough
you know similar enough that they were
cohesive and different enough that they
were
um
they were brilliant as kind of
standalone features and uh
i um
yeah it's it's certainly uh
it's certainly hard to puzzle out and i
think actually one of the things that
comedians often undervalue or perhaps
they don't speak about enough is the um
self awareness
when people
almost more important than wit i think
is self awareness if you if i know more
about you and this is in small amounts
if i know more about you than you do
you're [ __ ] okay that you're just
immediately not funny it's over okay
it's totally over i cannot know
more about you
uh than you do and that's why when you
know these blokes do these jokes on
stage and they go the thing about women
is and you go well i'll immediately know
too much about you okay and much more
than you do you have some you know
middling to quite severe psychosexual
issues that you haven't worked through
and i can't laugh at you now because i
have the power and you don't okay
uh
[Laughter]
sorry
make myself laugh and um
uh
you know i remember seeing all sorts of
that's that's that's why in his in his
tiny amount as you can't go on stage
with your zip undone or like your fly
undone and then everybody goes well lost
it yeah okay you've lost your power
sorry
or up to
we can tell that there's something up
uh
with you and because of the kind of
jokes that you're doing why are you
choosing to say that yes why are you
choosing to tell us that and even if uh
audiences aren't conscious of it they'll
sort of subconsciously interpret your
weakness
unless they are as weak as you which is
why
you know
more basic comedians tend to have more
basic crowds
so there's a
youtube channel that i found yesterday
called comedy without errors have you
seen this
no bro interested it is
awesome it is so sick so it's a a guy
british guy who obviously really really
[ __ ] understands comedy and he's just
done breakdowns of different comedic
styles so james a caster's got a 30 or
40 minute breakdown where he explains
all of the different elements of how it
worked in terms of storylines on there
um oh my god he's got a
he's got one about dave chappelle and
about how dave chappelle uses call backs
he's got one about uh how to deal with
hecklers and it's it's part of a body of
work there's three different styles of
doing comedy without errors [ __ ]
outstanding
youtube channel i was fascinated i
thought it was really really [ __ ]
cool big shout out to comedy without
errors comedy without errors uh i want
to talk about um
being a dad and when you
start to do like dad stuff
because
i'm not dad yet
that i know of
and
the the gulf between me
and my father
when he was my father he still is my
father but you know what i mean when i
was a child and things needed to do age
doing like diy
or going to the sh did you just dad [ __ ]
right i just feel like there are certain
archetypal dad qualities
that i don't have
do they what happens do you do a course
is do they just arise
uh i think that there is an element of
um uh sinking uh well trying to swim and
indeed sinking uh or or or puzzling it
out i don't think it's ever been easier
because there are lots of youtube
tutorials on how to um
and how to
re-surface your deck
which is i think
you know pretty
i think that's like advanced dadding
isn't it
uh
you know when you get your uh power
washer and you power or wash off all the
old varnish and you re-varnish your your
debt that's peak dad um
i was pretty bad at that and i think we
lost to the deposit on that flat
uh so i did have to make many apologies
to many different people sadly
uh but
[Laughter]
so stupid i repainted it orange and like
without asking the landlord what an
idiot uh tried to put up lots of shelves
but there was loads of like bits of
metal in the concrete so the drill
wouldn't go in so i couldn't put the i
felt like and this is locked down and
lockdown was my first
foray into um
[Music]
into it
into into trying to do the more diy
stuff in terms of being a provider i
earn significantly less than my partner
jesse so i mean i i do understand
there is a
maybe an evolutionary impulse that you
have to overcome to want to kind of come
home with a zebra in your jaws and say
look what i got for everybody isn't it
great that i made sure that everybody's
still alive
i
and there's an extent to which i feel
or feel decorative as a father
[Laughter]
the sperm donor that stayed around
yeah like
this sperm donor is keen isn't he look
at it still knocking about after seven
years
um
[Music]
so i
i
i mean i'm really grateful for uh my but
she
like when you're looking at her with the
newborn and you see her breastfeeding
and then
like earning the money as well you think
what shall i
what shall i do
shall i just am i should i can i go to
the pub then if you're gonna do that if
you've got everything sorted if you've
got if you've got a handle on everything
i'll just go out and see vaz for a bit
he's cooking um
a goose or something
uh
there you go chappelle there's a call
back yeah uh
so
yeah i mean it made me feel incredibly
uneasy and i think perhaps i
overcompensated with my desire to be
a shelf uh putting up father type person
but um
[Music]
yeah
you know
uh
there we are there is there is
definitely a sense especially i think in
earlier when when kids are just born i
mean again this is all voyeuristic the
second and third order told to me
but that
for instance everybody
who was
in
high high echelons of the us marines
and he's been to war multiple times done
tons and tons of tours and said that
he's never felt more helpless alone or
scared than watching his wife give birth
to their first child
because there is nothing that he can do
it is entirely on that person it's
completely out of his hands and he just
has to sit there
with his [ __ ] hands in between his
legs just yeah
waiting
i uh
i
i i on the birth of a third child
because of uh covid's i don't know if
you've heard of that um
there was nobody allowed in the hospital
uh so i had to kind of come in only when
i was asked for specific junctures don't
come in a second before we like
literally crowning and then call him up
uh so not quite that urgent but i
couldn't stay with her the night and i
usually for the usually we have so many
kids
pumping them out all the time yeah um
so i would have slept for the previous
two
on um
on the on the seat that they have beside
the bed
uh and
uh
and it's so awkward and for
i mean for a dad i think in any of those
situations going to scans going to
it and they don't talk to you either and
it's same when you're looking around a
school really it's just like you just
get ignored like because maybe the head
teacher doesn't know how to talk to you
or like oh my god i remember like
sitting in the
i remember sitting in the uh in the
waiting room not the delivery
the
waiting room before we
go down to before it all kind of kicks
off in the labor department
and they have to come in and check her
every now and again to see how dilated
she is which means that you have to sit
in a chair and sort of
like how like you know when you try on
shoes and you forget how to walk
like some pretty midwife comes and
sticks her fingers inside your
girlfriend and you kind of go i wonder i
don't know what the ceiling's like it's
just amazing the ceiling i love the
ceiling now
and it was so bizarre like watching her
root around like her fingers inside like
that i'd sort of that's
i tried to make it hot for myself
and then and the sweetest thing is as
soon as she left i went that's so
awkward i just the only and i said to
jessie the only way i could get through
that was i just i tried to make it hot
for myself and she went yeah me too
wow jesus i mean i think that shows that
you're a good player
yeah good match similar senses of uh
humor and depravity
um yeah yeah but and then during the so
i went home that night and then got a
call at 6 00 am
saying oh by the way i've just started
going into kind of like full labor so
any time that usually means you've got
about five or six hours before there's a
baby for any parents will know how
insane this is
i got there
quarter two the baby was out within five
minutes of my being there she went from
like one centimeter to fully dilated
in
like 45 minutes it was insane and
because
it was he came out so quickly you
usually the baby usually has lots of
fluids squeezed out on the way out
because it's a bit of a squeeze famously
and uh he didn't have enough of his
fluid pumped out so he had a lungs full
of
uh amniotic fluid so had to go straight
into the um icu for like seven days and
had strep b or something so had to be on
in
tubes and we just had kind of visiting
hours with the baby for uh
for a week so in terms of that was a
real and she was sleeping downstairs and
i would kind of go home look after the
kids
ordered too much pizza
um try and make the most of
yeah i'm ordering deliberation because
yeah because you're not allowed to tell
me not to a bottle of red wine
absolutely
um
and uh
would go in the next day and yeah the
powerless the powerlessness
uh extended itself over a week there
and there is a very real feeling of uh
wanting to do right but then not being
any
uh specific guidance or
um
or guidebook my brother is really really
into um weightlifting he finds uh social
interaction a bit more tricky
and uh
and i was speaking to him once and he
was sort of explaining to me that the
reason why he likes weightlifting so
much is that there's quantifiable
progress there is with social
interaction oh have i done well if you
could just score me 6.8 on the quality
of the chat that would be amazing just
so i know if i'm uh making tangible
improvements to my
my ability to interact uh
whereas weightlifting i i bench pressed
x amount last week i bench pressed x
amount this week my body fat percentage
or whatever your whatever your goals are
at home
uh you know is x and now was what and
you know it's it's it's it's easily
there's numbers there that you can look
at and go
progress
uh and i think you know with shelves i
can put shelves up and go look some
shelves but i can't
get scored or
like was i good at being a a partner
during the delivery of a child and then
for the subsequent week whilst it was
in the um
uh the the the intensive care unit
um
i have no idea which is sort of
frustrating you just have to trust that
you did do
something that constitutes your best and
you were well meaning like whenever
anybody
i'm awful at talking to people when
they've got a serious illness
if somebody's got a serious illness and
i talk to them i kind of go hello and
all i can sort of think to say is
how are you how are you
you don't want to say how are you
because i know that you've got like a
disease and it's bad so you can't go how
are you because we both know so what
should we do here should we just go i'm
sorry that you've and it often is that
you should say something as simple as
i'm so sorry to hear about your illness
that's absolutely [ __ ] yes
but then you don't want to say illness
to them because they might have been
that might have been the five minutes
that day that they were just forgotten
they were thinking about alfie's coming
over he's going to cheer me he's coming
up he's going to cheer me up and then
get
diseased just managed to get that
disease out of my head
uh
so yeah life is a constant um
array uh an obstacle course of
social pitfalls and uh wrong things to
do and thank god we
have uh shelves to put up and
weights to lift so that we can [ __ ]
get something done so at the end of my
life i can look back on a series of
shelves and weights and think
at least i believed this thing
i left this for the world yeah i think
that's why i like getting my ear wax out
my ears so much i've look i've produced
something
that's a [ __ ] low bar
so i i heard this story um from a
psychologist i spoke to a couple of
months ago
and he said that during world war ii
there were these patients who were
completely catatonic in psychiatric
wards in london completely comatose
unresponsive just roll them over clean
the bedpan feed them however however you
feed them nurses would do this thing
unresponsive for years and years and
years
uh bombs start falling during the blitz
and there are
fewer ambulance and fire truck drivers
then there are ambulances and fire
trucks to drive so there's this shortage
and these men
mostly men most people in psychiatric
wards were men uh these men got up
people had been comatose for years and
years and years got up out of bed and
started driving fire trucks and
ambulances around london helping out and
his point was that um
male mentality in terms of goal setting
also depression but principally goal
setting is done based on trying to
do things if you give a man the ability
to a goal the ability to achieve it
he'll crawl over broken glass with a
smile was his argument um
and you see this with these men that
they were motivated out of completely
comatose state to go and do a thing and
i think that that's the difference when
you look at what women are motivated by
you know a woman
i would guess on average
more so would be happy just being
emotional support
if if women
had children with other women or you
know in lesbian relationships where you
one of the
girls is pregnant or whatever the one
that's in the corner is perhaps more
likely to just i was there for emotional
support i felt whereas your compulsion
to to do a thing
yeah is actually
quite restrictive
yes i think during uh lockdown i a lot
of the time i said
when people would say
you know i i wasn't too much of a drag
that i said this to absolutely everybody
but you know when my mum would ask me
how i was i would often say oh well not
so good actually because i've had my
i've had my purpose taken away
uh and
feeling like
your purpose is now
well it's gone
that does send you you know not to the
psychiatric facility uh although you
know given you know let's do a fourth
lockdown and see where we are um
i
incredibly incredibly depressed and
missed it all so much and i think i
missed
i spoke to my uh hairdresser who i do go
and see on a quarterly basis and um
and
he said
first haircut i got after lockdown
i said how did you find it and he said i
just missed being good at something
and uh and i thought that's such a good
quote yeah i almost started weeping
uh yeah i missed being big or something
yeah and i mean i started trying to do
bits and pieces and i started doing
instagram lives in the hope that that
might
uh uh you know put a little uh nicotine
patch over the craving
but
it didn't because you've developed a set
a very specific set of skills
uh that
suited to stand up so
uh
very hard to get that to translate and
also the
endorphins and the and and the and the
the experience of communicating with a
group
in a live sense and having something
as
the the messily
emotional reality of other people who
are present
it was gone because it would just be you
say something funny on instagram live
then a flutter of hearts coming up
that's all you've got i mean
that feels good but it doesn't feel that
good the reason that the reason i went
to go and see you in edinburgh was
because slos had told me that i should
do it's like hey man i'm up this weekend
who should i go and see and he said
alfie brown's got a show no sean like go
go see that and um
but he he said the same he was he was
having arguments with his girlfriend
now fiance that he has the most perfect
relationship with
because he needed her to love him like
500 strangers a night
[Laughter]
and he was he was she was still doing
her thing and he was moping around the
house smoking weed and playing xbox
badly and poking her and being hey
what are you doing
hey yeah
love me
yes i think i you know
i did a lot of
i can remember once my girlfriend was
trying to watch um that sally rooney
thing that seemed to
like after every single episode you go
how was that only 20 minutes long it
felt like it was going on forever anyway
um i would i was like i remember
bouncing on the trampoline
and like because we bought the kids a
trampoline during lockdown and just like
a little exercise trampoline that you
use the old people used to strengthen
their bones and um
she was trying to watch normal people i
was bouncing on the trampoline staring
at her kind of
like why aren't you looking at me like
and like and then i and then i looked at
myself and thought
i've gone
i've i've gone mad this is like not this
is not an appropriate way for an adult
man to be but i was so starved of
everything
uh that i just couldn't i could i could
barely function and when
i'd speak to comedians who say they
didn't miss it i
there is no
stronger and more vociferous [ __ ] you
that i have for anybody else in the
world don't do it then don't do it
because you just you know
your gigs are gigs that i could have
i'll have yours then because i'll do two
i'll do two i'll do one for me and one
for you and i'll do them both with a
smile on my face because you've had to
jump up and down on a trampoline to
assuage your feelings of uselessness uh
yeah i've been singing i've been i
learned the moana wrap to impress my
children like i've there is no depth to
which i haven't stooped to try and
feel relevant again extract some screed
of
do i have your love am i entertaining
you have i made your life better have i
illuminated
the torpor of our everyday experiences
for you and then in between that between
this kind of mad
uh court jester type character to
slumped in an armchair
staring at a book i'm not reading didn't
read one book during lockdown uh
i mean an incredible sense of atrophy to
the whole experience of everyday life
and then and and nothing no
no
no ability to go and
do the thing that you
love to do yeah
it's it's dude this is the thing
so few people have spoken about lockdown
after lockdown i think everyone kind of
was a bit bored of the same conversation
over and over again oh it's hard isn't
it
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah you getting on
all right yeah yeah i am i am you know
getting by and people we had that
for so long that
that conversation kind of just feels a
bit like old hat but the echoes
right the reverberations and some of
those situations and the realizations
that you had that this is the time if
you had a strategic learning experience
like you did which was there is a part
of me there is a void which gets filled
by the art form that i have chosen to
express myself in um
that realization is really really
[ __ ] important
and by not having the conversations
about it you actually don't end up
perhaps learning and then maybe even
transcending some of the suffering that
you went through during the time
yeah and i think
like the really
this is to be taken with a kind of pinch
of salt because i'm but my jesse's
brother my partner jesse's brother is a
doctor
and i went man this must remember
meeting up socially distance in a park
last year and i went mate how are you
doing this is just awful like how are
you how are you coping and he went mate
this is like
this is much worse for you than it is
for me
because i didn't become a doctor because
i
i didn't want to have to like work to
save people's lives obviously it's
harrowing and awful and i think you know
what he was saying is to be taken with a
pinch of salt because obviously it was
nightmarish but at the same time
that
he had his purple that's his call to
arms he had his he had his calling uh
met and it was very difficult and
horrific and for much of the time but
i thought it was so interesting when he
said that such a bizarre thing for
uh
maybe not because i think maybe i mean
we don't know we only know about people
who were saying
it's like one of those things it must be
so hard for doctors that you know let's
all think about the doctors worse for
them it is for everybody else maybe all
the doctors were thinking no no no this
is why we this is why we got into what
the [ __ ] is everyone clapping us for you
clapping our souls that sat at home
wanking five times a day they're the
ones that need our support in this
difficult time
god if only i had the spirit in me to
wank five times a day so i was here's
another one man i
having a conversation with a buddy about
a year ago
we
i can't remember where we were some some
bar somewhere and we've been talking
about something and then we were going
away we're doing a little bit of work
and then in between bits of working chat
out of the blue he turned to me and said
man
how much how much do you think you come
i thought
what do you mean like volume yeah yeah
yeah so
let's say that there's a sort of
percentile right from zero to 100
where where do you think you fall in
terms of the volume of semen
that you create upon
climax
and i didn't really know what to say
because the only times
that unfortunately i've made it to the
end of a porn video
to watch
the man
complete
yeah
i don't think that that's a
representative sample of
men of
semen for men and
so i
explained this to him and i was like i i
[ __ ] like like a normal like probably
a normal amount probably 50 probably
50th percentile
and then quick as a flash he went i'm
95th percentile
okay
tell me about that and he said frankly
bit of a nuisance if i'm honest
that was
that was his
i
i worked out when i was i think about 25
years old
that
uh i'd been wanking at that point for
about 13 and a half years
and i probably hadn't missed a day of an
average i'd been going every day i
worked out what the average uh
[ __ ]
weighed yeah what it was for a man uh so
i started working for 13 and a half
years ago at that point my kid brother
was 13. so i started wanking around the
time he was born although i don't think
they were related incidents
um and i
i've worked out that if i'd uh
saved all my [ __ ] like in its weight
since the day i started wanking i'd have
about seven and a half stone of [ __ ]
which is about the weight
of a 13 year old boy
so
interestingly like human beings grow
at the same like amount that you shed
every day
income
and i could have like if i'd saved it i
could made my own like cam brother
some disgusting x-rated snowman yeah
from the people who bought you the human
centipede
it's come brother york is gone brother
wow
this is this this this podcast has been
quite high and low hasn't it yet we've
gone to the depths of deep depression in
lockdown and also we've got to come
brother i want to know about your
speaking of atrophy and weightlifting i
want to know about your fitness journey
because you're starting a
a foray into
health and wellness are you not well i'm
so incredibly um
[Music]
i'm so incredibly gullible and so
incredibly uh
like
i have a
sort of fantasy idea of the of the man
that i would be
and
if you look at him in his com com like
in his complete form
all of his facets are incompatible with
each other so there's a heavy drinking
guy who's in great shape and you're
immediately done
because i love
i'm i'm a good pint and i like i haven't
quite worked out this kind of balance
yet whereby i managed to and i saw that
i was at a kind of crossroads as it were
in terms of
being
a
like a 34 year old father of three
just eating
all their food all the time and
and being exhausted so having to just
fuel yourself on
scraps and you know
like endless packets of oat cakes with
the hummus in the fridge and
then feeling like was that really a meal
or am i
doesn't i should still eat a meal i'll
eat a meal as well
um
so i just don't think i had very good
habits and then like you know loads of
red wine and
and great beer anyway i mean
so a fitness journey i'm not sure like
fitness is quite a highfalutin word to
you know i i don't want my knees and my
heart to give out by the time i'm 45.
journey is the kind of journey i'm
avoiding i'm avoiding the diseases of
kings from the middle ages if i can
evade gout by 50 i'm going to consider
this a success i don't want gout
although you know gout is a kind of like
an emblem of
it's a really
yeah yeah it's like how soldiers get a
purple heart you know people
looshes get down
right so you're trying to
just extend your mortality a little bit
i've started doing high-intensity
interval training courses i don't like
spelling here because it's got two eyes
in it so it sounds crap
um
and
uh
and i do them with uh energized and um
wonderful gorgeous
men and women
shouting at me uh and
in a gym or at home
in a gym in a gym i go to a yeah they're
like a fitness class people around the
corner and it's brilliant and actually
that's the best thing i've ever done
when i'm at the gym i spend the whole
time you know
on
twitter getting angry and listening to a
podcast and
yawning at the bench press
thing
so and i and i don't do any cardio
because it's too awful so
uh and i don't also it's it's the same
fitness to me is the same as having a
podcast i just want somebody who knows
everything to be able to go
here's how long the podcast should be
here's uh what you should do on youtube
here's what you should cut up onto reels
here's how often you should do it here's
the best day to put it out here's uh if
you should do instagram tv as well
here's how to market it on twitter
there's all your information go away do
that and if it's good then it'll work
and if it's not then it won't and it
also if it's not good it still might
work because you know and if it's good
it's still who knows but you know at
least you know that you're doing the
right thing and the fitness thing as
well is like oh shall i eat
shall i eat slow carbs should i focus on
my gut health shall i eat butter coffee
and like a
i mean which is disgusting and i'm you
know predominantly vegan anyway so it
would have to be sunflower butter coffee
which i'm not even sure really works
because i'm not sure if the science
abides by sunflower butter coffee
um or should i just cut fat out or
should i just count calories or should i
do intermittent fasting and all of these
things can i just have
somebody say to me
what's effective please and then i'll
just
do it and and and have done with it and
it'll be so much easier to
uh
to to to keep off this uh
this layer of dad fat that i've
accumulated over the last three or four
years
um
and and
if i'm keeping it off that yeah that's
easier isn't it it's easier to keep it
off than it is to get rid of it correct
yeah well man i think you've reached if
i was to give a bunch of different
advice to someone that was doing what
you were doing
the first thing i would say is join a
class because you outsource your
accountability and your motivation and
your intensity to a group of people you
get a bit of money and your and your
money but [ __ ] man
that's that's one of the things that i
really don't get i understand if you
have legitimate financial restrictions
that do not permit you to be able to pay
between 70 and 180 pounds per month to
get someone to shout at you and tell you
what exercises to do in a class setting
i understand yeah but if you have the
money and you're choosing to spend it
elsewhere and complaining about your
fitness goals that's a you problem like
that's you
not doing the thing that you should do
in order to get the goals that you're
saying that you want you're complaining
about not getting the results that you
didn't get from the work that you didn't
put in that's what your problem is so
class is number one like it's so good
man even i i've been training for 15 16
years and i still rely on classes where
my motivation's a little bit low so i'll
just go and do them for a few months
build a little bit of motivation back up
and then coast on some some programming
if i want to do a little bit of stuff
myself
that's awesome
and then on programming yeah so um
the
what you pay for or the uh compromise
that you make with the class
is that if there is a particular
modality of training that you want to do
let's say that you really want to work
on getting your resting heart rate down
or improving your cardiovascular fitness
or you want to spend some time doing
hypertrophy because you want to gain
weight or whatever it is um you are at
the mercy of whatever the class is doing
and you can find different classes one
class may be a bit more lightweight more
cardio or maybe a bit more heavy one
maybe a bit more complex
but you are never doing precisely the
program that perhaps you would want to
do let's say you want to work on your
chest and
the the classes only do chest once a
week or not at all um
so that's the sacrifice that you make
but i find that if you use the classes
for motivation and then you can kind of
coast
back into some some custom stuff if you
want to do that or not
um and then
with regards to the diet and the other
things like that
that is a [ __ ] minefield i have a
bunch of buddies who
they they've made their careers out of
telling people that
almost every different diet that people
are trying to sell you is [ __ ]
horseshit
and
calories counting calories is literally
all that matters and there is there is
an entire industry a counter culture
industry of people that is
they've made their careers out of saying
it's just [ __ ] calories bro
yeah um i
uh
i i like all that i'm fond of it um but
i
i mean
it's not surely it's not because then if
you have i mean it obviously to anything
because then you have to kind of get
things like
you know enough protein so that you're
servicing and like you could you might
just be calories but you might be
what you're eating and the quality of
food that you're eating will have a huge
effect on your mood if you do loads of
great exercise with some
gorgeous um
man shouting at you
uh
and you eat you know uh
i don't know honey haribo only honey
um then you'll feel shitty oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah
in terms of weight loss um it is
literally just calories now you can
improve your weight loss and your mood
and your gut health and everything else
on top of that and your performance by
getting your macros right so you've got
maybe a bit more protein than you think
that you might do and you avoid
processed carbs you avoid
too much saturated fat and blah blah
blah but i think
what most people do is they repurpose
diets like keto which is a restriction
diet or intermittent fasting which is a
restriction diet or atkins which is a
restriction diet or vegan or [ __ ]
pescetarian or whatever it is most of
most diets come down to restricting some
different food groups that you're not
supposed to eat yeah and then people go
well look i lost weight on this diet and
you well yes obviously because you cut
out
two-thirds of all foods
and then someone else did the complete
opposite diet cut out two-thirds of all
foods but two-thirds of different foods
that included the foods that the other
person ate so i understand why it's
why it's complicated i think also a lot
of the um
fitness uh
kind of the culture around it and the
way in which people talk about it and
try and puzzle it out
is
difficult for me to
first of all there's a kind of whole
vernacular to penetrate and like you
know your program said a bunch of things
of programming modes and stuff i and i
kind of can't and there's also and this
is really stupid and i and it's um
it's something that i'm prone to do
quite a lot
whereby i'm
cynical about something
because i
am
jealous of it or suspicious or have
preconceived ideas about the archetypes
involved i think as it was
like fitness idiots being fitness idiots
and talking all their jargon
um
and uh
and i'm prone to think that at the same
time as wanting all the like but i look
at them go but it'd be great to look
like you obviously but um but shut up
so
that's where i have it and then i look
at my heroes and think what who nobody
that i loved was you know going on about
their
uh speaking openly about their fitness
goals christopher hitchens never once
mentioned his fitness goals but then he
is dead
like way too soon yeah because by his
own admission he burnt the candle at
both ends and it shone a bright light so
i think i'm not going to
stop uh drinking i mean my job takes
place mainly in the pub
um
but i
i do want to find a way to balance
uh
the life that i would like to lead
um with
uh
with with with being healthy and feeling
energetic and you know not having such
ruched eye bags the whole time i
honestly think if you do
four good classes a week
and you're under the age of probably
45
that
you you can pretty much get away with
whatever you want
unless you have unless you have a
metabolism that's
a bit sub-optimal or you have a
propensity to gain weight quite easily
but
if you're training consistently and hard
and you're doing progressive overload i
i struggle to see if there's people that
go to the classes
that i know of that literally do not
care about their diet but if you're
training five days a week and you're
doing it quite hard they're in [ __ ]
great shape because their body's just
desperately trying to accumulate
whatever it is that lovely merlot from
last night and the remainder of the
cupcakes from little johnny's birthday
party for halloween
and it just thinks well he's [ __ ]
pushing us really really hard here we
need to
we find right get the cupcake get them
can we have we got any more merlot left
we'll use that i do i do always find the
mood is quite a good gauge of uh you
know what's going on i thought because i
mean i was doing these classes and
thinking my mood is absolutely in the
toilet
um
i'm and but i was eating really well or
you know well healthily and then i'd
need to be my body used would this would
be me eating well for a sedentary
lifestyle
so now that i've got you know gorgeous
bloat screaming at me for 60 minutes you
know a few times a week
i need to
recalibrate properly well means because
that is
absolutely not sustainable i tried
here's another thing that i tried that i
was thinking about
because you talked about getting into
soup i think when i saw you live but you
did something to do with soup
and it made me it made me think about a
brief period
where i tried to get into candles so i
thought
i wanted a thing
you know you you feel like you need a
thing yeah you you want a it's this is
going to be so what are you into
oh is this during lockdown yes it feels
like a lockdown obsession correct yes
so beeswax soy wax all different incense
varieties
ones that burn in and they combine and
the wax is kind of together but then
when you burn them it it congeals and
you get multiple different
uh and i really got into candles and i
just it got me thinking about people
that want a thing
quite badly and i wanted a thing and i
tried to make it candles and all that i
achieved was i
coated um
the ceiling of this room in so much soot
that came off the candles that i
actually needed to get it paid to be
repainted
oh good god that's really funny so how
and how long did it last for you this
session probably about four months i
think
um
but probably between four and six months
i tried i'd kind of
done it once before and not really
committed
thought that that might be my thing
and now the nails in the coffin that
it's not it's not my thing
christ
um what
how old are you 33
and how many things do you think you've
taken on post the age of 25 do you think
that have been i mean this is one yeah
yeah so most of them have been
commercial projects because i'm a
ruthless
religious capitalist yeah precisely yeah
who is trying to fill the void with
money uh but
fair
not many not as many as i not as many as
a lot of my friends a lot of my friends
have tried to try to do to try to do the
thing how about you have you been have
you been getting a thing or the kids
kids are kind of a thing
uh kids are kind of a thing um i suppose
uh
i know i've i've fantasized about a
thing i've a motorbike
no no no no no no no no no i remember as
a child my uh father uh said we were at
theme park and he went do you want to go
on the big ride and i went no
it's horrible why would i want to do
that and he went good
good that's a and he said good do you
know what that means that means you've
got a good instinct
you want to stay alive
and that means that you'll be
you know
you've got your head in the right place
life might not be very exciting but it
shouldn't be dead
yeah why why would you want to oh peril
like why would you want to feel that
makes no sense
so
so i
uh yeah the same reason i don't want to
ride a motorbike i don't want to ride a
bicycle i just i don't
at all want why put myself in that
position
you're you know people get scared about
terrorists on the tube
you know you're much more likely to get
knocked off your bike than you are
than you are blown up on the tube
it's been years since that happened
uh i'd like to learn a language i'd
really like to learn a language and i'm
i'm i think i'm reaching the
it's reaching crunch time and i'd like
to and what i'd really like to do and
this podcast and doing all this
i've started my own podcast listener
link in my show notes below
link in show notes below thank you um
thank you
uh i
and and learning all about this and
going back to what we were saying about
fitness and indeed podcasting i want to
know everything about it so i've watched
hours and hours of charismatic 20 year
olds from sacramento telling me about
algorithms
and
why you don't know anything and
but what i do feel like is that youtube
is
incredibly incredibly exciting the whole
idea of being a youtuber
is it's sort of a pejorative term
youtuber it's like well
youtube's just
you don't call inkmark bergman a
cinemara it's just where it's on isn't
it it's any it's literally anything you
can put you can do a feature film and
stick it on youtube does that make you a
youtuber
no it just means that you're putting so
you can do anything all these
programs that they're putting on to dave
and comedy central none of which i'm in
well they're not making them because
they're really expensive to make
precisely the opposite they're making
them because they're cheap and given
they're cheap i'm staring into a sony
camera that's good enough to so i can
just go i could go to brussels and show
you all what it was like for me in
brussels and if you like brussels and if
you like me then you're like watching
that and it doesn't have to be me being
a youtuber there it can be me
engaging in an
and a funny and intellectual way with
the experience of travel with somebody
or not with somebody and i could film a
bit of the gig that i do there and it
it's it's or i could film my own feet
and draw faces on them and i could do
whatever i want and i don't need to go
to a
development producer to have a
conversation about whether or not my
feet would work on it no i get to make
that choice and i'd people speak about
you were speaking about the algorithm to
me before like i'd i'd much rather
compromise with an algorithm than i
would a development producer
at least the algorithm will be honest
with me
like or be
be straight with me yeah well and i
don't actually have to talk to it it's
the other key thing
there are some brilliant development
producers i will add but
there are some you know man i think that
the i think that the venture into
youtube for pretty much every comedian
that i know is a [ __ ] great idea so
many like what most youtubers are trying
to repurpose
is what comedians have learned on stage
or classic theater actors or especially
people that do improv and stuff like
that like jesus
uh and then you look at someone
logan paul is a good example of this so
love him i hate him that guy is a
[ __ ] media genius so you put him in
front of a camera and his ability to
control the cadence and the timbre and
the tone and the way that he speaks and
what he says is
[ __ ] it's media training it's
post-media training media training and
he's so [ __ ] effective and he learned
it by just doing daily vlogs for a bunch
of years and yeah he [ __ ] up and did
made some mistakes or whatever but the
guy is [ __ ] hot absolutely [ __ ] hot at
what he does and you think
every comedian that i know
that does podcasting on youtube
is a killer all of them
there isn't anybody that you port across
onto this medium that's done it for an
appreciable amount of time
standing on stage that isn't
[ __ ] well well well more competent
because they understand about pacing and
they understand about joke structure and
they're comfortable with silence all of
the things that takes
a normal person that does this
forever with no feedback with feedback
from us a silent lens
that looks like the borrowing thing
about it is that
speaking into this and going hello this
is my podcast and then suddenly it's
your uh
your your
then it's out there and you go was that
funny am i bad shall i
you know shall i go away for a long time
like what's
what what am i and what was that and was
it good and oh god what did i say and um
uh yeah it's it's it's at the immediacy
of the feedback and
the beauty of stand-up is that it has to
die in the room it's beautiful because
it dies like a flower
uh exactly uh and
that's what's scarier about stuff like
this but i mean there is an extent to
which well if the thing that's going to
get made i'm going to be on on tv would
just be me traveling about and
meeting people anyway well i can do that
shortcut yeah exactly um there's
speaking about logan paul i think that's
so interesting i will look at his videos
now despite the fact that um
there have been
you know moments of bad man about him
uh love him i hate him as you as as you
say i actually have no idea what it is
he's supposed to have done so i'm not
sure how uh what you're supposed to love
or hate about him yeah how extravagantly
i should be going no boom
or like you know to be uh to be woke
adjacent
um
so yeah
there's a really good youtube video by a
guy that i love called nerdwriter have
you heard of him no uh brilliant video
essays and does a brilliant one on how
donald trump answers a question and
there's exactly the same
there's like
the simplicity of the language the fact
that he structures every single one of
his sentences is an answer to have the
key word tremendous bad people
tremendous bad people we get we get the
key word of what he wants to get across
it's going to be horrible it's going to
be horrible tremendous bad people bad
people and it's every single line you
could take out of context and know
exactly
what he's saying they did they he
examines the the reading level of all uh
uh presidential nominees over the past
few years
and like so mick huckabee and bernie
sanders are way up there at a level
reading level um
and then you've got like clinton down a
bit and other clinton down a bit and
you've got uh george bush down a bit and
then you've got way down at like
kindergarten sort of just above
like early years reading level is that's
how donald trump speaks and that's why
everybody gets it and that's why
everybody understands and that's why
everybody
immediately well i know what that guy
thinks there's no there's no two ways
about it and it's not about how many
people hate him
like the interesting thing when hillary
clinton was campaigning i thought
uh they had this slogan love trump's
hate
well it it did
because the people who voted for donald
trump loved donald trump and the people
who didn't vote for donald trump didn't
love hillary clinton they hated donald
trump and love did trump hate in that
election but just not in the way that
hillary clinton thought it would or
wanted it to so that was the smartest
tagline
ever
yeah yeah yeah but she just didn't
realize
yeah well i mean it was yeah samantha's
tagline for him
it was oh god that was such a sad night
but uh
yeah it's a really interesting video
essay that i'd recommend you and
all this is nerd writer he's got a bunch
of good stuff there was a
article that i saw that looked at
how much
democrats and republicans love their own
party versus hate the other party
yeah and
for almost all of time it was that you
you voted for the party that you wanted
to be in as opposed to not voting for
the party that you don't want to be in
uh and 2012 that changed so now it's
it's literally like a a protest vote it
is everywhere everyone is protest voting
against the side that they dislike and
this is this is a a whole other
[ __ ] rabbit hole but
the fact that
out group hatred is stronger than
in-group bonding
is a
really [ __ ] interesting mechanism
that you see at the moment the fact that
most people bind together over mutual
distaste of another as opposed to mutual
love of someone or something within that
circle i think that's that's so
interesting
yeah it's uh it's i think i don't know
where it's come from i think it's
i think it's very uh we haven't learned
how to deal with new media yet uh new
digital media social media etc and um
there's really interesting um
if you look at the invention of the pa
the printing press
was exactly when you had like in late
19th century so 18
17 something well i can't remember the
exact date but right directly after the
invention of the printing press you had
this huge rise in populism uh and the
the the the corn laws being bought in
and everybody's saying well now the
papers exist everybody can just be
taught what to think and it's the death
of democracy
and
it's something that we're to an extent
experiencing again we learnt
sort of arguably how to deal with papers
or how to ingest them or uh perhaps
uh
perhaps the way that papers went
you know social media took on
it it carried the extremities carried on
kind of further in each direction
obviously papers got wind of the fact
that sensationalist news stories sold
copies selling copies earns money and
earning money means that we're all
you know we can all buy new cameras and
whatnot and that's you know that's
that's that's that's where we all are
we're all you know i i made my the title
of my episode something i thought was
juicy because
that made it click
yes we're all thinking like this
um
so
given that we haven't learned how to
use this media yet i think with a little
bit of time maybe that
stops or we
learn that
there's some sort of
cognitive revolution whereby we switch
away
uh from anger and that
the algorithm stops serving anger and
utilizing it as the
touch paper for
all virality and
explosive
news
that there is and we we get to a new
place there has to be something to push
us past this which i kind of remain
optimistic there there will be but i
don't know what it is and on the left
and on the right i think people have
confused
uh
and this is without you know this is not
a shameless plug but the
reason why my show is called sensitive
man
is that i think sensitivity is something
that we have completely
sort of expelled from all discourse and
people confuse
or people or perhaps uh you know on the
on the on the left the the corbyn left
would say that they are
sensitive they are but i
i think that true sensitivity is the
only thing that can defeat righteousness
and righteousness is what you have at
either end and sensitivity is completely
anathema to to to to to that
um
so a call for sensitivity i'm reading a
book a
proof
of johann hari's new book johann hari
rose
lost connections and chasing the scream
so it's in a book see the guy that did
that um he said the controversial stuff
about mental
health
um yeah well his books about mental
health i don't know how controversial it
ended up being he said that it was a
combination of
of environmental and biological but he
put less
weight
on the biological it's just imbalances
of chemicals in the brain bro um so it
may well i mean he wrote a book on on
mental health i don't know how much yeah
no i think the uh the guardian did a uh
the guardian and everybody i follow on
twitter did a takedown of it uh sounds
like okay yeah again everything that's
controversial is controversial depending
on
our own uh algorithmically interpreted
version of reality yeah um anyway he got
a shellacking from lots of people that i
saw i didn't know and uh
i i
well everything every criticism that
everybody had of him
i kind of had to under my breath go oh
yes but i do agree with him about all of
it
yeah i think um that was what i've been
saying about mental health for such a
long time and i even did a
uh
i did a keynote speech at keel
university about um
about about this about you know the the
the the uh not over diagnosis but
diagnostics
being
in
uh
the diagnostic element of mental health
taking away from the human aspect of it
it dehumanizes it slightly and we're
getting away from the kind of emotional
human experience of
and i think that causes a sense of
detachment from what's going on that
isn't necessarily helpful people like
the labels because it gives them it
brings some order to the chaos of their
phenomenological experience yes and it
gives us something helpful to put on our
log line as well correct yeah exactly
it's like
autistic only fools and horses
depressed in a caravan site
yay
well remembered um so
yeah he's got a new book out uh called
stolen focus and
it's about uh why we're more distracted
why our attention is is being robbed of
us and stuff and i'm only one chapter in
for the people that want to listen to
this it won't be out until january the
book isn't out till january and he's not
coming on till january
but it's a big book and bloomsbury sent
me a super super early proof um
and it's really interesting really
[ __ ] interesting and the first
chapter
talks about the fact that we have more
information coming in
than we can actually filter that we have
a surplus of information and what it
causes us to do is we need to utilize
filtering in a way that we never would
have had to before so humans are
information foragers where
squirrels look for nuts and trees we
look for information because information
kept us alive the problem is for almost
all of history we had a scarcity of
information we would get a story we'd
hear the same [ __ ] story from the
elders of the tribe
150 times and that's how you get stories
and myths that are passed down right
it's passed down and passed down and
passed out you've heard it so many times
whereas now
you have
an abundance of information almost all
of which is noise and almost none of
which is signal most of which is
manipulated or contrived or whatever
so our filtering mechanism just is not
tuned up to be able to do this
and it's all done along the
narrative of johann going to some island
uh in near america and taking getting
rid of all of his technology while he
writes
the chunk of the big a big chunk of this
book uh so he's down he down regulates
all of his information as he's trying to
write about it and then he sort of it
puts his personal journey of
down regulation and
and re-centering his uh
his thoughts and his uh stimulus how
much stimulus he's got um and it's
really [ __ ] interesting man so that's
that's coming out that sounds brilliant
and i think a lot of the problem that i
have with non-fiction is the uh
is the fact that it it
i i just kind of can't take it all i
mean ironically um uh given what the
book's about i can't take all the
information so you're reading this
book uh and think i can't i just don't
and i have suspicions with some
non-fiction books like i don't think the
god delusion needed to be that long
that you just wanted to sell a big book
just didn't need as a vanity thing okay
richard didn't need to be that long give
it to me
in 200 pages okay can't do it dude
averages don't do it um
but
uh i have a suspicion with
i mean that's a narrative a nominal
narrative journey i think is what was
missing from a lot of that sort of thing
uh gives it a human element right this
is there's definitely because i mean
that behind me is
all of that and all of that is just
books books and books and books from
publishers from people who've got books
coming out and they are awesome
uh most of them are awesome but there
are some
the books with which i resonate the most
are the ones that have personal elements
and stories woven throughout this is why
james clear's atomic habits was so good
because it wasn't just this
rote memorization game of how to do
habits it was
illustrated with examples from team gb
cycling or from the chinese
weightlifting team or from a speed
reader or from someone that knows 17
languages or something that it was
illustrated with personal examples and
james sort of brought some of himself in
there and he talked about his own
journey but uh yeah one of the other
things he said about the the diagnostic
criteria and the labeling
i spoke to robert ploman who's a
behavioral geneticist so he looks at the
heritability of everything that we are
right
everything psychologically whether that
be your dyslexia or your propensity to
fart or how tall you are or how much you
come um he looks at the heritability of
all of these different things
and
one of his problems that he has is with
labels because what you're talking about
is a spectrum
a particular
common collection of traits
that tend to come together that elicit
an outcome that we have given a label to
that's dyslexia but there isn't a point
at which you're not dyslexic and now are
you just have varying degrees of the
traits of being someone who struggles
with these sorts of things or
[ __ ] is good at maths or whatever it
might be and he
thinks that we're going to actually
start to dispense with labels we've had
kind of a surgence of labels and that's
increasing at the moment but he thinks
that's going to taper off and people are
just going to go back to i'm good at i'm
bad at i'm my kid struggles to sit still
in class as opposed to my child has a
adhd and
there's another one now the boisterous
boisterous boy syndrome or some [ __ ]
like that which is like it's just that's
just a young that's a 13 year old
boy
diagnostic and statistical manual five
uh there is a mental illness uh
one is caffeine addiction
uh
uh which is what you were drinking a
non-caffeinated correct i haven't had
caffeine this year
have you not no i'm hard as [ __ ] that's
why because i like to suffer
unnecessarily i'm interested in that but
um
[Music]
another one is adolescent rebellion
disorder
that is that's just all teenagers uh i
mean i hope it's not mine and you know
however many years time but
it was certainly uh me i mean it's just
of course it's not why do we need to
why does that need to be part of our
diagnostic and statistics uh it doesn't
really feel like it does
uh and and it
removes
the humanity from the thing that these
people labeling you just like
your brain is kind of full of hormones
of course like of course you've gone a
bit mad your body's
shifting into this
huge like huge new
uh
form like
it's it's crazy what's happening to you
so we'll all be patient and
understanding and you go
mad and the more and i will be
nice to each other about it i don't
yeah i've never really understood the
uh uh uh
uh our
the necessity of
these labels but i suppose it is because
um
[Music]
yeah we we maybe we find comfort in them
or people like outsourcing kind of thing
that they perhaps were
ashamed of but now we've taken away the
shame of
like the stigma against mental health is
you know going going going
but when does that change into the
stigma against sadness i'm really sad at
the moment but sad is such an underused
word
because it
it feels like oh i've had depression
well that's bad have a day off work i'm
really sad at the moment okay well grow
up chop chop yeah [ __ ] come on
uh
so yeah it's a really interesting thing
to uh go into uh but again it's one of
those things that because everybody's
either been diagnosed or know somebody
who has it's very
um people are incredibly protective over
uh the way that it's come to be
um
but uh you know i have an open mind in
either direction
why have you stopped drinking coffee i
just wanted to see if i could do it this
year
so i
did a thousand days without alcohol
um as a promoter just because i wanted
more time and more money and more
productivity and consistency and stuff
and that ended up being
really good
really good thing for me to do
did you stop did you end a thousand days
a thousand days thousands of days yeah
so i did i've done six months and a year
previously and then decided to do i was
gonna do two years and the two years
would have taken me into the middle of
lockdown and i thought breaking it
during lockdown feels a bit pointless so
i'll just keep going
and then set a new target and the target
was a thousand days uh so that was good
and then i
just decided to start a video you've
started drinking again i'm now back
drinking alcohol albeit
at
the most lightweight levels you have
i am i'm back to i've regressed back to
a 15 year old's tolerance of alcohol
it's terrifying
really i stopped drinking for two years
and when i came back to it
i
knocked off eight pints of guinness [ __ ]
absolutely nothing really
yeah
it was wow so bizarre oh dude one one
beer gives me a buzz now one soul a 330
mil soul
gives me a buzz like i'm sneaking it out
of my dad's cupboard when he doesn't
know
during lunch break from college between
a.s sociology and as business studies
come back home and sneak a soul because
that's what the rebellious kids do so
and then caffeine just thought i i don't
i quite like the idea of not being
controlled by a substance
um
big fan of yeah of personal sovereignty
and just thinking right okay well let's
see what happens
nothing has happened apart from the fact
that my sleep's improved nothing nothing
i didn't get headaches i didn't have
withdrawal symptoms
how much coffee are you drinking because
i gave up coffee for about a month and
my my back pain was unbelievable back
when i gave up
oh the
when i gave up coffee i could hardly sit
down because my back pain was so bad
do you have you researched why what's
related between coffee and your back
oh yeah it's your kidneys it's your
kidneys going what the [ __ ] is going on
where's all our stuff
who's taken all of our stuff
so they're kind of throbbing and
expanding and contracting and going
mental because you've like you just yeah
yeah there you go on treat yourself to
that willy lads you know we'll have lots
of lovely diuretic and lots of lovely
pissing and you know wakey wakey
everybody and
uh so i think if you are going to quit
caffeine the way to do it is with green
tea
pills and then just take it down
gradually don't go from you know three
london coffee shop barista coffees a day
to
nil so i would have usually had a coffee
upon waking
another
potentially mid-morning
and then a caffeinated version of this
knocko which is
150 milligrams
of caffeine so that's probably about
that's closer to two cups i think or one
very large cup that was a
fairly decent amount yeah fairly fairly
good consumption but i just nothing
changed it felt like i'd been gaslit
by coffee into believing that i needed
to have it in my life
uh and between that and decaf
i've just ticked over
quite nicely
okay yeah well i love that i love the
ritual of it uh and adore the taste do
you
grind grind your own
no i think if i had uh i think that's a
no kids thing
because if you've got i think 15 minutes
in the day to make a coffee something's
gone wrong with the children because one
of them's missing or something i could
do it but i like leaving the house uh
and i like um i like going to my
uh coffee shop and sitting down and
reading the news and making notes on
whatever what do you order what's your
order
uh an oat flat white or oat latte
that's me
that's me oh flat white's a good
it's a solid coffee
or a black filter
i like filter coffee as well uh and if
i'm going to a
if i think it's a if it's if it's going
to be crap coffee i'd rather have black
coffee yeah black filters that's exactly
the same so we do a series on here
called life hacks and one of the life
hacks a couple of months ago was
if you're uncertain about the quality of
the coffee just go black filter and put
a little bit of sweetener in it if you
don't like it too bitter and you
it'll almost always be okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah whereas a bad latte
is just undrinkable feasibly but
unfeasibly bad alfie brown ladies and
gentlemen where should people go if they
want to
harass your podcast
uh ladies and gentlemen uh it's on
youtube it's also on all of the other
places where we find podcasts uh i don't
know where you listen to yours um but
yeah
check out the youtube if you're on the
youtubes uh and subscribe because i've
got more stuff i've got a
qriket
web series coming out on there soon
which if you like that sport
and me
then you're gonna love it
um yeah but i'm alfie brown comedian on
on youtube and on instagram and whatnot
thanks for having me mate my pleasure
man what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you